Треба відвезти вагони в Маріуполь тому, що,
там буде крутий фестиваль, реально типу.
І треба, щоб люди якби їздили.
Я до того навіть не був на сході [України] жодного разу.
І уявлення про Маріуполь як такий були зовсім не такі,
яким ми його побачили.
Тому що це ніякий не розвалений схід.
Ну, тобто центр Маріуполя і якщо до моря,
це реально такий приазовський стиль
з такими там за висотою будинками.
Дуже прикольно, дуже чілово.
Та я вже тут як свій, знаєте.
Кароче, отаке.
Коли того року ГогольFest перебрався в Маріуполь,
з'явилася ідея зробити такий собі ГогольTrain,
але це можна було б назвати ГогольВагон.
Я тоді поїхав просто як один з пасажирів, так би мовити.
Для багатьох, так само як і для мене,
це була перша поїздка на схід України.
І схід виявився зовсім не такий,
як багато людей собі уявляли.
Це класне, сучасне місто.
Я зараз про Маріуполь говорю.
Наповнене життям, наповнене, я не знаю,
хіпстерськими кав'ярнями, барами.
І, звичайно, ну,
це був доволі успішний проєкт,
і цього року замахнулися на те, щоб зробити більше.
Вагон — це класно, два вагони — тоже непогано,
але потяг — це круто.
А ще, якщо це потяг —
не просто там n-на кількість вагонів,
причеплена до якогось потяга,
а це — твій потяг.
Це потяг, який везе всю вашу тусовку,
спеціально виставлений для вас,
і він везе все це в Маріуполь.
Ну а далі ми пішли, ну...
А було б класно його розмалювати,
а було б класно зробити там ще тусу,
а було б класно зробити там ще концерт,
а було б класно зробити то, сьо, інше.
Ми все це запропонували це Укрзалізниці,
вона сказала: «Нєвапрос».
Ми віримо в те,
що все можна зробити через діалог.
Не через зв'язки, хабарі, насилля,
а через просто спілкування.
Ти приходиш з божевільною ідеєю, ти її пояснюєш,
і люди думають: «Блін, ну прикольно,
давайте, давайте спробуємо».
Ти приходиш...
Ми прийшли вже з начальством Укрзалізниці,
Нам показали вагони, які можна фарбувати.
Вибігає провідниця, каже типу:
«Нізя! Це ж адєскиє вагони, шо ви робите?
Мене ж вб'ють там!»
Ми кажем: «Ну ми там заступники там таких-то».
Вона говорить: «Я нічьо не знаю, я з Одеси,
тіпа я тут вопшє маю їхати в Маріуполь!»
Значить, бере цей один з заступників, дзвонить комусь,
видно, дуже важливому,
шось говорить: «Да, угу, угу».
Показує, кому він дзвонить.
«Компанія сказала фарбувати».
І я кажу...
А тут стоїть Рома, він під псевдонімом Чів, він мураліст,
малює великі мурали.
Він уже стоїть із пензликом,
чекає команди, що можна...
«Рома!»
«Компанія сказала фарбувати!»
І він був першою людиною, яка легально
доторкнулася своїм мистецтвом до вагону Укрзалізниці.
Це був історичний момент.
Діма!
[російською] А от ця розмітка, коротше, фіолетова...
[російською] Думав почати почати
от з цієї штучки, коротше.
[російською] От, хотів поцікавитися...
[російською] Я не брався суто за лінії, розумієш.
[російською] Під котрі... Найбільш геометричні, розумієш.
[російською] Ну, тобто мінімально.
[російською] Загалом, далі так...
[російською] От, бачиш лінії? Бачиш, одна лінія чорна.
[російською] От я її додав, чорну лінію.
[російською] Потім, виходить...
У нас є 10 вагонів і 2 доби, щоб їх розмалювати.
Тут буде зображена велика голова Гоголя,
яка спостерігає за нинішнім
сучасним світом,
за нашим деструктивним побутом.
Вот, і тут буде зображено в абстракції
те, що відбувається навколо:
урбаністичний простір,
екологічна тема буде теж показана.
[російською] Багато людей можуть побачити як може бути.
[російською] Що типу потяги —
вони всі нудні якість, однотонні, одноманітні,
[російською] і з'явиться хоч один,
який буде, можливо, когось дратувати,
[російською] можливо, когось тішити,
не знаю, якось так.
Ми розмалювали, врешті-решт, вісім вагонів.
Оскільки один нам не дали розмалювати,
бо він щойно перефарбований.
А інший концептуально мав залишитись
нерозмальований, бо це — вагон-битовуха.
Вот, він у нас відображає
все те, що постійно є в нашому побуті.
І, зазвичай, там ще за радянських часів
прийнято якісь такі штуки ховати.
Ми не хотіли цього робити,
ми хотіли показати,
що окрім класних розмальованих вагонів,
гарних, яскравих, існують і такі вагони:
старі, подряпані, поржавілі,
трошки вже зношені.
Звичайна така олдова, олдскульна Україна,
вот,  і вона нікуди не дінеться,
і ми маємо, може, не намагатися
закрити очі на те, що відбувається.
А, може, прийняти її,
взяти її так само з собою в подорож.
Що ми, власне, і робимо.
[російською] На чому ти зараз зупинився?
[російською] Це таке задоволення — малювати в компанії.
[російською] Особливо, легально, да.
[російською] Іншого разу такого не буде, я тобі кажу.
Стоп.
Говорячи відкрито, є тут художники,
які до того малювали потяги.
Але малювали вони їх як:
ти підкрадаєшся вночі в депо,
береш балончик і просто малюєш,
поки тебе не зловлять, або ти не втечеш.
Один з провідників розказував,
що якось він спав, прокинувся,
а йому обмалювали вагон.
І йому довелося платити свої гроші, за те,
що він проспав на чергуванні.
І він це мені розказував,
поки він балончиком наводив літеру «Т».
У нас немає якоїсь однієї концепції на весь потяг,
як там якась одна тема, яка
наповнює його, тому, що після ГогольTrain
вагони розформують, і вони будуть їздити
такі самі розмальовані в складі інших потягів.
Тому робити одну велику картину ми не могли.
Тому ми вирішили зробити антологію.
Це — такий набір різних сюжетних історій,
але пов'язані між собою якоюсь спільною ідеєю.
Це — вагон-ресторан, який вже 10 років нікуди не їздив.
І невідомо, чи будуть його ганяти ше кудись.
Це дуже старий такий олдскульний вагон-ресторан,
який я останній раз бачив,
коли мені було років п'ять чи шість.
Чесно кажучи, це просто прикольно.
Просто прикольно зробити щось
не заради грошей, слави,
я не знаю, для того, щоб комусь щось довести
чи поставити в портфоліо.
Просто є ідея,
і вона настільки крута,
настільки насичена,
що ти просто не можеш стати осторонь.
[російською] Всі на фестиваль?
[російською] Звісно.
[російською] Звісно ж.
[російською] Київ—Маріуполь!
[російською] Він іде! Він їде!!!
Да, ти можеш тепер видихнути.
Проект дуже різко став надто масштабним.
У нас просто фізично не вистачало секунд
всьо робити і всьо менеджити.
Ми просто вирували,
в плані там по три години спимо.
Кожен день — це гора мільйон завдань.
Вся команда, яка працює,
вони працюють повністю безкоштовно.
Вони всі свої таски переносять там на місяці вперед.
І коли сьогодні поїзд під'їхав на перон,
забитий [обмальований] повністю балонами...
Це — перший в Східній Європі потяг,
який реально забитий.
Кожен вагон, він має свою назву.
Наприклад, в нас є вагон-битовуха,
вагон-діалог, common future,  parallel realities,
journey, подорож типу,
різноманіття, сучасна українська культура.
І в принципі, художники були ознайомлені з цими брифами,
і вони малювали їх в такому стилі.
Якщо ви робите якусь ініціативу в свому місті,
вам не буде складно
налагодити питання з владою.
Тому що влада на місцях або інфраструктура,
у них є достатньо широкі можливості,
щоб допомогти вам, і їм самим буде цікаво.
Ну ти просто кажеш: «А ми би хотіли поїзд».
А вони такі: «Окей».
І це круто.
— [російською] А можна не обмежувати себе в пензлях?
— [російською] Можна.
— [російською] Але ви тільки дуже-дуже делікатно.
— [російською] Дуже делікатно.
Звісно, і пальцем можна. Це чудова ідея.
— [російською] Колір кохання.
— [російською] Прекрасно.
[російською] Колір любові до мистецтва.
[російською] Де би мені отут таке маленьке сердечко намалювати?
Ти їдеш через міста, поле,
а люди, які збоку там просто проходять,
вони бачать, як несеться
просто забитий малюнками поїзд.
У тебе там є червоний фільтр і просто...
Просто несеться.
У цьому поїзді хто їде?
Реформатори, громадський сектор, креативний клас.
Люди, яким просто цікаво побувати в такому двіжі.
Музиканти, артисти, ЗМІ, медіа.
Всі тулять [тут: їдуть поїздом] просто,
бо це круто і всьо.
Тут не треба багато чого пояснювати.
Альо?
Це просто приклад, прецент і гайд [путівник],
який вийде після трейну [потяга],
для будь-якої культурної ініціативи
незалежно від масштабу,
про те, як взаємодіяти з тим,
щоб створити мобільність.
І це ще більший імпульс до того, щоб люди їхали.
Ну, якби, цих майже чотириста людей,
на жаль, не буде на ГогольФесті,
не було імпульсу, не був прописаний шлях.